-Guys, you probably
heard me talking about
the new Ford F-150 Lightning.
It is the all-new electric --
all-electric new Ford truck.
I'm freaking out about it.
It is awesome.
I have an F-150.
And I use it to haul pumpkins...
-Yup.
-...and listen to country music.
But this truck --
This truck, they've taken
to the next level.
It is getting
crazy-good reviews.
It has 10 kilowatts
of electricity.
So you can power your house
for three days from the truck.
[ Audience oohs ]
It could power
a wedding reception
in Yosemite National Park.
They did it. I saw it.
It can go from zero to 60
in 4.6 seconds.
-What?!
[ Audience oohs ]
What?!
-It's got it. It's got outlets.
It's got everything.
It's -- Giant touchscreens.
It's the coolest-looking thing
I've seen.
It's got this flip-down
armrest thing.
It's just --
The whole thing is insane.
And it's roomy. I sat in it.
It's actually more roomier
than my first apartment
here in the city.
-That's true.
-But on top of it all,
it has a trunk --
get ready for this --
in the front.
-What?
-'Cause the engine's gone,
dudes.
-What?!
-The engine's somewhere in the
unders. In the undercarriage.
Yeah, I don't know where it is.
The engine --
-It's not there.
-They have a front trunk.
-What do they call it?
-They call it
a Mega Power Frunk.
-Oy!
-I love it.
I cannot wait to get this thing.
F-150 Lightning.
But I'm not the only one
who loves the thing.
It's already, like, a giant hit.
There's a band out there,
they wrote a song about it.
They're a Swedish pop duo
called Frunke.
-Frunke? With a...
-They're called Frunke.
And the song is called
"Junk in my Frunk."
It's all about the things
that you can do with your frunk.
Anyway, they just
released a video for it,
and we're about to debut it
for you right now.
Ladies and gentlemen,
here's the world premiere
of Frunke's new video,
"Junk in my Frunk"!
[ Cheers and applause ]
[ Zapping ]
♪ Front ♪
♪ Trunk ♪
♪ Frunk ♪
♪♪
♪ When the trunk's in the front,
then the truck's got frunk ♪
♪ So I store my stuff
in the truck's big frunk ♪
♪ Plug a boombox in
to bump the crunk ♪
♪ Then I hit the road
with my junk in the frunk ♪
♪ Got a sunk in my frunk,
a "Hunk" in my frunk ♪
♪ Headlamp on to spelunk
in my frunk ♪
♪ Bass amp up,
play funk in my frunk ♪
♪ Check the score,
slam dunk in my frunk ♪
♪ Boogie boards
to catch a wave ♪
♪ With disco ball
to start a rave ♪
♪ With camping gear
when I've got to brave it ♪
♪ Rubber duckies
I like to bathe with ♪
♪ What you thunk in my frunk
that I sunk in my frunk? ♪
♪ I became a professor,
went adjunct in my frunk ♪
♪ Then I shrunk in my frunk,
chipmunks in my frunk ♪
-♪ Stole my style,
went punk in my frunk ♪
-♪ Got an easel
if I'm feeling arty ♪
♪ Did a plant-store run
'cause the mums are hardy ♪
♪ Computer lab
'cause I'm a smarty ♪
♪ And a lot of watermelon
for my patio party ♪
♪ When the trunk's in the front,
then the truck's got frunk ♪
♪ So I store my stuff
in the truck's big frunk ♪
♪ Plug a boombox in
to bump the crunk ♪
♪ Then I hit the road
with my junk in the frunk ♪
[ Zapping ]
[ Cheers and applause ]
-Ah. Oh, my God.
-I love that.
Thank you to our friends at Ford
for helping us out with that.
To learn more about the Ford
F-150 Lightning, go to ford.com.
I cannot wait for this thing.